welcome to exploring computing
today's video is working with files
so in this video we're going to talk
about how to read from files
and write to files and so this is going
to greatly
increase your capacity to create useful
python programs um so let's go ahead and
start off by
seeing how to open files so it's really
pretty straightforward we just go ahead
and say open
we pass in the name of the file that we
want to work with
and that file is going to be located in
the same location as your
python file so wherever you save your
python file
that's where you can expect the data
file to appear if you're creating a new
data file
or that's where your data file should be
placed if you're planning to read from
the file
okay so open uh the name of the file
notice that
that is a string followed by second
string which is going to tell
python if we're going to read from the
file right from it use a
string with just an r character in it if
we're going to read and just a string
with a w
character in it if we're going to write
and so um
that whole open will return a value
which we can use to
access the file all right
now if we try to read from a file that
doesn't exist python is actually going
to give us an error message when we try
and run it
if we try to write to file that doesn't
exist python will create a new file
and if we write to file that is already
there that already does exist
python will overwrite it so be careful
that you don't
write to file that you care about the
contents
because it will get overwritten if you
tell python to write
to it okay once you're done with the
file you should
explicitly close it so uh you do this by
using the name of the variable which
refers to the file
followed by a dot or period followed by
close
probably the easiest way to read from
files is to use the for loops which we
saw last lecture
so in this first example we're going to
take a look at how to read from a file
and
add a series of numbers that are found
within the file
this is going to turn out to be quite
similar to
the program that we saw in the previous
lecture where we added up all the
numbers in a
list but there is a little bit of extra
messiness here
so you can see up at the top i start off
by opening up the file
um in this case i always open up the
file name data.txt
and i'm opening up to read from the file
i am not going to write from the file
and then at the bottom i go ahead and
close the file
now this middle section here looks
pretty similar to
what we saw in the previous lecture
where we looped through all the items in
a
in a list and added them all together
and we're actually going to take a look
at a direct comparison in just a second
there is one difference here though and
that is we need to explicitly convert
the
uh whatever we're reading from the file
into an integer we could also convert to
floating point number if we want it
and this is because when we read from a
file
python always treats whatever we've read
from the file as a string
okay so here's a example which we could
actually run and so on the right i have
the actual data file
and then we've got our code on the uh on
the left
and so the way this is going to work is
uh we've got a little for loop there
for line in data file and line is
initially going to be set to 100 then
it's going to be set to 200
then it's going to be set to 150 and
then it's going to be set to 400
and other than that this will work
exactly like the previous
example of um if you have trouble
understanding that you should take a
look at the previous video
on for loops all right so when this is
all done
this is going to print out 850 and
here's a direct comparison between
our example from last lecture and
today's lecture and you can see that
the code is almost exactly the same um
obviously
in our code for today we are opening up
the file and we are closing it
and i will have to admit i changed the
print statement so one of them prints
total is and the other one just prints
the total
um but other than that and the fact that
we are explicitly converting
the data from the file to an integer
because again when we read the data from
the file
python is going to treat it as a string
not a number so i do need to do that
conversion
all right so uh it is possible to read
from a file
outside of a loop um this gets a little
bit messier
uh but this can definitely be useful in
certain circumstances
and so you can see here i open up the
data file same as before
and then there's this data
datafile.readline and that will read
uh the current line in the file uh it
will return it as a string
and we can do something with it in this
particular case i'm converting it to a
floating point number because
again would normally be treated as a
string of course you may want to treat
it as a string
um we'll actually talk about that next
lecture with the issues with treating as
a stringer
after we read the last line of the file
the next line we try and read there
won't be another next line because we've
reached the end of the file
what you'll actually get back from the
read line is what's referred to as the
empty string this is a string with no
characters in it
you may wonder what happens if you have
an empty line in the file a little bit
earlier in
the file so maybe i've got three lines
with people's names in it i've got
two blank lines then i've got a couple
more lines with people's names on it
it's actually going to turn out when you
read a line from python
um and it's blank you're actually going
to get that carriage return character
remember
when we talked about ascii we talked
about how there actually is
actually talked about how there are
several different ways to encode
the end of the line with a new carriage
return i mean you're actually going to
get that character returned character
uh read back from you from the file and
again we will talk about
this next lecture what it means what it
looks like and what to do about it
so what about writing to file so writing
to a file is pretty straightforward
we can go ahead and open the file for
writing we can say
datafile.right or whatever the name of
your variables that's that's storing a
reference to the file.right
and then whatever the string you want to
write to it is and again you should
close it when you're done if you do
forget to close it on some systems
you won't actually get any output in the
file what can happen is
the computer can sort of save up all the
stuff that you're writing to the file
and not actually write it to the file
until you explicitly close the file so
do make sure that you explicitly close
the file
and just as a reminder if the file does
not exist
opening a file for writing will create
it whereas opening a
non-existent file for reading will give
you an error message
and if a file does exist and you open it
for writing
you are going to overwrite the current
contents of that file
all right there's another little issue
that you're going to run it to if you
start writing to the file
so here i've opened the file
stanford.txt for writing
and i've written to the file twice i've
written go stanford and go
cardinal and if we were actually to open
up the file what we would see is go
stanford go cardinal all on the same
line
uh we'll see how to fix this in the next
lecture but i just wanted to mention
here if you were to go ahead and try to
do the right here
so let's take a look at a couple more
examples of increasing complexity
in this first case i'm going to go ahead
and
average the numbers in a file this will
be similar to something we saw
last lecture but again it's got some
complexities that we'll need to deal
with
so in the last example we just always
open the file called data.txt
in this case what we're going to do is
we're going to go ahead and ask the user
what the name of the file they want us
to open is
and then i will go ahead and call open
on that particular file name
the center section here i go ahead and
set total equal to zero
and then i go ahead and iterate through
all the
lines in the file this is basically what
we did a minute ago
very similar but the little wrinkle here
in this case is
last time when we determined the average
of the numbers in a list
we needed to determine how many items
were the list and there was that length
function
which is called length on the list
itself and it would tell us how long it
is
that's not the case on a file if i want
to know how many lines are in a file i'm
going to have to determine it myself
and so here's how i'm going to do that
i'm going to
use a variable called number i'm going
to set the initial value to number
to zero so initially we haven't seen any
numbers yet
and then in the middle of my for loop
notice that's indented so this is
something that's going to happen for
each line in the file
i'm going to add one to the number so
initially number will be zero when we
see the first line i'll say number
equals number plus one
so number will go to one and the next
time i run it number will be one i add
one to it it'll be two
add one to it'll be three and so on and
when we're all done numbers should be
the number of lines that we've actually
read from the file
and then we can just go ahead and take
our total and divide that by the number
all right uh let's take a look at a even
more complicated example
um so this is going to determine how
many adults we have and how many
children we have
and if we have anybody who's 17 my
apologies
we're going to count you as a child for
the purposes of this program
uh but you know if this were a movie
theater something hopefully you get a
slightly cheaper ticket
okay so i opened the file at the
beginning
i asked the user what file name they
want to use so again
this is slightly more complicated than
what we've seen before where i just
always open the same file name
and then when we're done we need to
remember to close it okay up at the top
after i've opened the file i go ahead
and initialize my variables and this is
super super common we've seen this in
the last couple examples
this is very common technique so we are
processing individual items in the list
we're trying to get
data about those individual items in the
list and
i need to store the results in some
variables and before i start
the loop before i i start processing
each of the lines
in the list or each of the lines in the
file
i need to initialize those values so in
this case i'm keep track of the number
of adults i'm keeping track of the
number of children
and before i process any of those lines
the total of each is going to be zero
and then you can see what i'm doing here
is i'm looking at each of the individual
ages in the data file
and uh if that age is greater than or
equal to 18 then i'm saying hey i have
one more adult than however many adults
i have seen previously
prior to processing this particular line
of of the data file
and if uh the age is less than 18
then uh however many children i've seen
so far i have one more child
um and so you can kind of think that
through and at the end of all of this
you can see that the adults variable
should store the number of
ages we've seen over uh 18
18 or or older i always got to remember
that whether that's greater than or
equal to or greater than in this case
it's greater than or equal so
if it's your 18th birthday today
congratulations you count as adult we're
gonna charge you more money to enter our
theater
and then we know how many children we
have at the end
so we just go ahead and print those two
out
okay that's it for our discussion on
files you guys will get to play around a
little bit with this
in your next homework assignment